aujourd'hui je reçois une nouvelle
invitée il s'agit de ma nombril et comme
les autres avant elle elle va nous
parler de sa particularité physique et
après on ira boire des coups avec les
potes mais ça c'est une autre histoire
avec et c'est parce que c'est le nom de
taché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nombril et doctorante en histoire et
youtube sur la chaîne c'est une autre
histoire
[Musique]
bonjour maintenant c'est ali alors est
ce que tu peux médias quelle est la
particularité physique et j'ai du
psoriasis est mort jeudi trop triste
j'ai du psoriasis
[Rires]
le psoriasis est une inflammation
chronique de la peau le système
immunitaire s'attaque à sa propre peau
qui doit se renouveler peu plus
rapidement que d'habitude
est ce que tu te souviens quand c'est
apparu ou quand tu t'es rendu compte que
c'était quelque chose que tout le monde
avait pas ouais en fait je m'en suis
rendu compte parce que j'en ai pas tout
jouer et ça a commencé alors on
réfléchissait avec mes parents mais je
pense que c'était à l'adolescence à ce
que j'ai compris à travers tous les
dermatos que j'ai pu voir et où il ya
des moments comme ça dans la vie où
c'est assez sceptique de se déclencher
donc l'adolescence évidemment qu'ils
espéraient seulement charmante pour
plein de gens et même sa peur beaucoup
d'internautes alive tu vois 50 balais
c'est possible de quoi et du coup m
c'était je pense en retour de 4e 3e un
truc comme ça du coup ça c'est une bonne
chose plus comment le première fois
alors du coup ça a commencé sur le cuir
chevelu d'abord et du coup donc en fait
alors le psoriasis et les cellules de ta
peau qui se renouvelle plus vite que
nécessaire et du coup par endroits sur
ton corps à sa fédé ça fait des croûtes
en fait parce que le l'epo supérieur qui
enfin les supérieurs de l'aide mortes et
où en gros sa future journée là ça fait
des croûtes blanche donc pas des croûtes
rouge de ce en quoi
et du coup moi ça avait commencé sur le
cuir chevelu et derrière les oreilles
ici et c'était un peu vénère quand
j'étais ado c'était beaucoup plus fort
que ce que j'ai maintenant donc bad à l
oreille notamment sa souverainté par
exemple donc c'était assez dégueu et
complexant dans mon malheur ça l'est
parce que comme c'était sur la tête avec
les chevaux en voyait pas trop par
contre ça me faisait beaucoup de
véhicules
ça mettait mal à l'aise et les
traitements que j'avais pour soigner sa
était très grave donc ça me faisait les
cheveux gras peut-être
là c'était assez gênant pour ça mais
mais après ça s'est beaucoup atténué par
contre plus tard je n'y a qu'au début
c'était que là il ya plus de quatre cinq
six ans par là j'ai fait une grosse
poussée sur tout le corps et du coup bah
voilà et et maintenant tu vois jean
louis sur les coudes alors là c'est
relativement soft en ce moment donc
c'est pas hyper ripper tu vois ça se
voit mais speight arriver j'en ai pas
mal c'est sûr les gens de tout ça dépend
des endroits ça fait des petites gouttes
tu vois comme ça ouais voilà et j'en ai
un peu sur le ventre ça dépend des
périodes et des moments tu vois c'est
plus ou moins fort et comme c'est assez
lié aux psychologies qu un tel cas de
stress ça ressort après tu traites où ça
finit par set
visuellement le psoriasis ça se
manifeste de façon différente selon les
cas et à des endroits différents du
corps et c'est souvent des plaques avec
une accumulation de peaux mortes
j'imagine qu'à un moment où il ya un
dermato kit a expliqué que c'était une
maladie que tu allais avoir toute ta vie
avec des crises et des moments de
rémission entre guillemets mais le jour
où tu as appris ça parce que tu te
souviens de
ce que tu t'es disait ce que c'était
déjà à l'adolescence ou est-ce que
c'était plus tard ouais alors en fait
moi pendant très longtemps je pensais
que je mente débarrasserait donc j'ai
enfin vraiment on a essayé plein
traitement et tout et tu sais alors ce
qui marche le mieux c'est les
corticoïdes
quant à red star bien et du coup je
pensais vraiment que j'arriverai à faire
partir ça est en fait la plus tard j'ai
appris à vivre avec et j'ai complètement
un bandeau décider elle-même en fait ça
me gêne plus du tout sûr j'y pense pas
après du coup c'est plus simple puisque
ce que j'ai eu dans ma vie même si c'est
plus étalé brutalement c'est moins épais
mais plus étalés et du coup par exemple
s'assurer plus du tout il n'y a rien
donc ça c'est répugnant désagréable et
douloureux tu vois mais là c'est plus
qu'à et du coup ça ne dérange pas du
tout je l'assumé totalement
du temps en temps on fait la réflexion
genre un peu début et tout mais moi
vraiment maintenant je m'en fiche
totalement
donc à l'époque j'ai pensé que ce à
partir et puis les années passant je me
suis rendu compte que ça partait pas ou
en tout cas à un moment c'est là puis
après c'est plus là c'est un autre
endroit françois sa part jamais
totalement ya des mots j'en ai très peu
de beaucoup plus mais par 11 victoires
c'est une maladie qui touche 2 % de la
population mais il faut avoir des
prédispositions génétiques donc ça n'est
pas du tout contagieux parmi les
facteurs qui peuvent déclencher ou
aggraver les symptômes certains
médicaments
le stress la fatigue et à des souvenirs
de perdre de ta vie où ça a été
particulièrement pénible où tu l'a
vraiment moins bien vécu qu'à d'autres
moments et ben alors à l'adolescence du
coup avec ce que je disais alors ça en
fait du coup ouais en fait si tu veux
mon père et mettez de la crème
hydratante sur la tête et
du coup c'est ça qui me grey s'est
énormément les cheveux et c'était
l'enfer a enlevé avec les shampoings
donc ça me gêne énormément je vais vous
faire trois quatre ans quand j'avais
toujours les cheveux gras du coup je
préférais pas faire la grève avant des
pellicules et pas avoir les cheveux gras
je trouve ça moins aigus mais bref à
chacun ses goûts mais une fois où
vraiment ça m'avait beaucoup blessé je
me souviens de quand j'étais en colo une
animatrice quand moi j'étais gamine en
colo une animatrice que j'aimais
beaucoup qui avait vu mes oreilles qui
m'a fait ab telle extraterrestres ont
fait et tout ça mais trop blessée parce
que c'était une personne que j'adorais à
qui j'avais une relation un peu
privilégié et tout mais ce n'était pas
intentionnel et ni méchants évidemment
enfin la connaissance était pas du tout
son but mais donc là cette fois là je me
souviens que ça met beaucoup de blessés
et quand il ya 4 5 ans est apparu sur
tout mon corps là j'ai stressé beaucoup
en remises en main c'est à partir du
moment où ça a paru quelque part je sais
que sa part plus donc je vais en avoir
tout le temps là ça fait beaucoup badé
et en plus j'ai mis du temps à savoir
que cette équipe se ressaisisse
en fait ce qui s'est passé là-bas c'est
que c'est ma coloc de l'époque qui se
reconnaîtra je le ferais un coût mais
elle l'était en formation perry qu'hier
et m'avait posé un faux crâne ça ma tête
je pourrais attendre une photo c'était
très réussi ça grêle est très bien faite
choc donc pour faire sont loin d'être
des jo avec tous tes choix dessous et du
coup j'ai fait une réaction à la colle
qui fait le tour du pin qui colle le
faux crâne et où et quand elle l'a
enlevée alors d'abord j'ai eu une
couronne de boutons magnifique et puis
ça m'a fait une réaction sur tout le
corps et du coût d'un budget petit
énergie et pendant longtemps je pensais
c'était un examen quoi puis je suis allé
voir que des généralistes avant d'enfin
avant le boucher de dermato ont dit vous
était surtout pas au soleil c'était
l'été est tombé comme ça à dégoûter est
en fait chez le dermato genre majeur
levé non plus avec ou sans résister non
je me suis dit trop dur j'en avoir sur
tout le corps tout le temps est en fait
le soleil l'était ça fait vachement bien
donc ça c'est cool de l'été le sel et le
soleil ça fait vachement bien donc au
contraire faut mieux se mettre fin en
protégeant rédaction
mais vaut mieux s'exposer au soleil et
du coup finalement bas ça t'empêche pas
une minute profiter de tes vacances mais
rien est dans l'ordre de l'intimité
jusque là ça peut déranger les garçons
donc ça va et voilà du coup finalement
je les assume alors au début je suis
mince et tous ces partis j'en ai peur
tout le temps partout mais après dans
mon malheur c'est assez soft aussi il ya
des gens qui sont concrètement alité qui
ont des traitements très très lourd est
ou n'est ce pas le cas donc c'est aussi
pour ça que je suis avec tranquillement
le psoriasis à soignies on peut atténuer
les symptômes et la maladie elles
disparaissent jamais complètement est ce
que toi tu aborde le sujet spontanément
ou est ce que tu attends que ça vienne
dans la conversation
non mais ça viendra conversation parce
que maintenant j'y pense mais le bras tu
vois en fait de temps en temps j'ai
quelqu'un qui me dit allez c'est dégueu
et tous hâte à un problème ou machin la
touche dit waouh est celui de 120 10 est
rien et on générale jeudi inquiète c'est
pas contagieux
voilà c'est le premier truc que je dit
inquiétez pas contagieuse comprend que
sa tribune mais c'est pas contagieux et
en vrai c'est pas dégueu non plus c'est
bien pourquoi pas d'accord voici juste
et en général qui dit voilà quand tu dis
tu dis c'est pas contagieux les laurie
se détendent et tu dis c'est lié au
stress
ils sont ils se détendent et sont en
mode en pâtit kim est énervant mais tu
adores d'accord dans ce cas là on ne
fait pas chier voilà et dans l'intimité
bah ouais une photo de g j'ai dit bon je
te préviens gesa s'il était vraiment
gêné mais en général c'est quand on me
l'a demandé
enfin tu agis pense pas enfin il est bon
ce n'est pas moi tu es là complètement
intégré maintenant tu appelles du tout
aujourd'hui tu as encore des situations
comme ça sa pop et ses deux nouveaux
pénible des fois où ça vient de là bas
en ce moment par exemple là je suis en
train de traverser une phase un peu
intense et émotionnelle et du coup bah
ouais j'en ai pas mal fait j'ai remarqué
que c'était plus une période chiante et
après ça vient ça sort un peu après tu
vois en réaction donc ça se développe et
tout mais maintenant je le sais dans ces
cas là si c'est vraiment chiant il ya
quelques lots c'est un peu même
douloureux où ça gratte un peu dans ce
cas je vais chez le dermato pour être
apaisées par de tester djimou
traitements divers et variés qui marche
un temps puis moi je peux après même
fait des uv dermatologie c'est drôle
dans le tessin d'urgence deux minutes
dans une cabine avec des uv sélectionnés
avec telenet est à poil comme ça à deux
boutiques y aller les poignées parce
qu'il faut qu'on voit tout absolument
tout les coins de ton corps c'était
rigolo mais voilà c'est juste pour
atténuer le truc mais je sais que ça
partira jamais totalement et ce que
j'espère c'est en effet que ça soit
jamais trop trop développé au point où
ça me sam handicaperait parce qu'il ya
des gens pour qui sait de coco le regard
des autres hormis la monitrice de colo
c'est quelque chose qui te gêne et un
moment ou un autre de ta vie ou vraiment
que ça a été le cas à l'adolescence par
rapport à ça et aux pellicules ou un
truc comme ça mais tu vois j'ai du bol
parce que j'aurais pu en avoir sur la
gueule donc ça allait donc ça ça me
complique c'est enfin fait toujours
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que ça fait de bbq
et voilà et aujourd'hui ça me dérange
vraiment pas faim je sais pas je pense
qu'il faudrait que ce soit absolument
hyper méchant ou pas vraiment je
l'assumé totalement
ça arrive des fois le truc ici pas aux
agents non j'ai des potes qui me disent
un peu maladroitement sédégo un truc
comme ça mais ça ne touche pas du tout
en fait ou alors je pense fait pas ouais
enfin en tout cas ça fait bien longtemps
que ça m'a pas annie vexé nyonnais et
quand j'explique jeux d'image c'est
comme ça
oui c'est pas très joli franchement mon
fils est comme ça ne m'empêche pas
d'avoir des rapports sexuels ou en
amoureux bas je pense que c'est pas
gênant dans la vie quoi toi tu as
l'impression que tu as un truc
particulier qui est à l' algérie un
conseil que tu te donner au mois ce qui
s'est passé c'est du coup c'est d'abord
l'habitude c'est que c'est devenu
complètement banal et que du coup ça
m'affecter plus le premier truc c'est de
l'assumer
parce que comme n'importe quel des faux
problème et tout quand on essuie ainsi
les si la personne en face de toi a pour
but d'être méchantes est de te blesser
parce que ça peut être le cas
l'adolescence pas de victime des
moqueries les autres et tout aujourd'hui
bon je côtoie plutôt que des adultes
dont quand prévoyez gens font pas ça
mais c'est vrai que ça peut arriver au
collège ou au lycée
en général quand on essaye de t'attaquer
que tu montres que ça ne tient pas bah
ça marche pas parce que si but c'est de
te faire chier et que je fais pas chier
on va trouver autre chose pour chercher
ça marche pas tu vois et donc ça c'est
le premier truc ensuite il s'est juste
des gens qui sont parce que c'est
logique que les gens aient une réaction
faisant âme et à quoi va forcément du
dégoût mais au moins implicitement c'est
logique du respect c'est différent donc
et dans ce cas si tu dis tout de suite
moi je fais ça je dit inquiète c'est pas
contagieux et c'est dû au stress j'ai la
peau qui pèle en gros voilà j'ai des
croûtes c'est pas grave
bon en général on n'embête pas c'est
difficile je pense à partir du moment où
c'est un handicap de type
voilà c'était si c'est trop douloureux
c'est est alité effectivement là il faut
avoir un traitement très lourd et c'est
grave si c'est un petit problème de peau
comme machin on va les virer mais il y
aura de l'eczéma et tout je me sens que
c'est hyper courant quand même moi je
connais vraiment pas mal de personnes
turgeon et du coup bah vous inquiétez
pas de ça si vous poton sa fin c'est
banal en fait en banal c'est
c'est un plan que loue donc soyez cool à
chevaux pas de couilles du psoriasis
mais sachez qu'il y aura forcément
autour de vous et que peut-être même que
vous en rêvez sans savoir où j'en aurai
un jour ça peut vous arriver ça peut
changer mais il ya des gens dans ma
famille quand on en fait très très
tardivement par exemple vraiment à 50 60
ans et et c'est pas grave
enfin en tout cas moi je vis avec donc
ici c est pénible pour moi j'en veux
dire courage parce que c'est rien et
franchement c'est vraiment rien et moi
en tout cas ça m'empêche pas de pêcher
ok merci monroe cuisine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]